we saw in the last video that when you
multiply or you divide numbers or I
guess we should say when we divide
multiply or divide measurements your
result result can only have as many
significant digits as the as the thing
with the smallest significant digits
that you ended up multiplying and
dividing so just as a quick example if I
have two point two point zero zero times
I don't know let me three point five my
answer over here can only have two
significant digits this has two
significant digits this has three two
times three point five is seven and we
can get to one level one we can go 1-0
to the right of the decimal because we
can have two significant digits this was
three this is two we only limit it to
two because that was the smallest number
of significant digits we had in all of
the things that we were taking the
product of when we do addition and
subtraction it's a little bit different
and I'll do an example first I'll just
do kind of a numerical example first
then we'll think of a little bit more of
a real-world example and obviously even
my real-world examples aren't really
real world in the last video I talked
about laying down carpet and someone
rightfully pointed out hey if you're
laying down carpet you always want to
round up just because you don't want to
you know it's easier to cut carpet away
than to have to somehow glue carpet
there but that's a particular to carpet
I was just saying a general way to think
about precision and significant figures
but that was particularly to maybe
carpets or tiles but when you add when
you add or subtract when you add or
subtract now the significant digits or
the significant figures don't matter as
much as the actual precision of the
things that you're adding how many
decimal places do you go so for example
if I were to add one point two six and I
were to add it to let's say I were to
add it to two point three if you just
add these two numbers up and let's say
these are measurements so when you make
it this is clearly three significant
digits are we were able to measure to
the nearest hundredth here this is two
significant digits so three significant
digits this is two significant digits
we're able to measure to the nearest
tenth let me label this this is the
hundred hundredth the
is the tenth when you add or subtract
numbers your answer so if we just do
this if we just add these two numbers I
get what I get two point or I get three
point five six the sum or the difference
whatever you take you don't count
significant figures so you don't say hey
this can only have two significant
figures what you say is this can only be
as precise as the least precise thing
that I ever had over here the least
precise thing I had over here was 2.3 it
only went to the tenths place so on our
answer we can only go to the tenths
place
so we needed to we need to round this we
need to round this guy up because we
have a six right here so you round up so
if you care about significant figures
this is going to become this is going to
become a three point seven and I want to
be clear this time it worked out because
this also has two significant figures
this has two significant figures but
this could have been let me do another
situation you could have one point two
six plus one hundred and two point three
and then you would get obviously you
would get one hundred and three point
five six and in this situation this
obviously over here has four significant
figures this over here has three
significant figures but on our answer we
don't want to have three significant
figures we want to have be only as
precise as the least precise thing that
we added up the least precise thing we
only go one digit behind the decimal
over here so we can only go to the tents
only one digit behind the decimal there
so what's going to be round up to 103
point six and to see why that makes
sense let's do a little bit of an
example here with actually measuring
something so let's say I have a block
here let's say that I have a block let
me draw that block a little bit neater
and let's say we have a pretty good
meter stick and we're able to measure it
to the nearest centimeter we get it it
is two point zero nine two point zero
nine meters and let's say we have
another block let's say we have another
block and this is the other block right
over there and we are we have a let's
say we have even a more precise a meter
stick that can measure to the nearest
millimeter and we get this to be one
point nine zero one meter so we're
measuring to the nearest
milimeter and let's say that those
measurements were done a long time ago
and we don't have access to measure them
anymore but someone says how tall is it
if I were to stack the blue block on top
of the red block or the orange block or
whatever color that is so how high would
this height be well if you didn't care
about significant figures or precision
you would literally just add them up you
would add the one point nine zero one
plus the two point zero nine so let me
add those up so if you take one point
nine zero one and add that to two point
zero nine you get you get one plus
nothing is 1 0 plus nine is nine nine
plus zero is nine you get the decimal
point one plus two is three so you would
get three point nine nine one and the
problem with this the reason why this is
a little bit it's kind of
misrepresenting how precise your
measurement is is that you don't know
what if I told you that the tower is
three point nine nine one meters tall
I'm implying that I somehow was able to
measure the entire tower to the nearest
millimeter the reality is I was only
able to measure part of the tower to the
nearest millimeter this part of the
tower I was only able to measure the
nearest centimeter so to make it clear
that our measurement is only good to the
nearest centimeter because there's more
error here then you know it might it
might overwhelm whatever precision we
had on the middle of meters there to
make that clear we need to make this
only as precise as the least precise
thing that we're adding up so over here
the least precise thing was we went to
the hundredths so over here we have to
round to the hundredths and since one is
less than five we're going to round down
and so we can only legitimately say if
we want to represent what we did
properly that the tower is three point
nine nine meters and I also want to make
it clear that this doesn't just apply to
when there is a decimal point if I were
to tell you that let's say that I were
to measure let's say that I were to
measure let's say I were to measure a
building and I was only able to measure
the building to the nearest 10 feet so I
tell you that that building is three
hundred and fifty feet tall so this is
the building this is a building building
and let's say that there's a
manufacturer of radio antennas
so or radio towers and the manufacturer
has measured their tower to the nearest
foot and they say that their tower is 8
is 8 feet tall so notice here they
measure to the nearest 10 feet here they
measure to the nearest foot and actually
to make it clear because it once again
we as I said this is ambiguous it's not
100% clear how many significant figures
there are maybe it was exactly 350 feet
or maybe they just rounded to the
nearest 10 feet so a better way to
represent this they would be to say
instead of writing at 350 a better way
to write it would be 3.5 times 10 to the
2nd feet tall and when you write it in
scientific notation it makes it very
clear that there was only 3 there's only
2 significant digits here you only
measure to the nearest 10 feet other
ways to represent it you could write 350
this notation is done less but sometimes
the last significant digit has a line on
top of it or the last significant digit
has a line below it so either of those
are ways to specify this is probably the
least ambiguous but assuming that they
only measure to the nearest 10 feet how
would you out and someone would ask you
how tall is the building plus the tower
well your first reaction which is let's
just add the 350 plus 8 you would get
358 you would get 358 feet so this is
the building plus the tower is 358 feet
but once again we're misrepresenting it
we're making it look like we were able
to measure the combination to the
nearest foot well we were only able to
measure the tower to the nearest foot so
in order to represent our measurement at
the level of precision that we really
did we really have to round this to the
nearest 10 feet because that was our
least precise measurement so we would
really have to round this up 8 is
greater than or equal to 5 so we'll
round this up to 300 360 feet so once
again whatever is and and just to make
make it clear and what's it even this is
ambiguous maybe we put a line over it to
show that that is our level precision
but then we only have two significant
digits or we could write this as 3 point
6 times 10 to the 2nd which is just 100
three point six times ten to the second
feet and scientific notation and this
makes it very clear that we
we have two significant digits here